as of this month open mic events can
resume across our state that means
karaoke is back how you can do it safely
rocky theist is live inside the palazzo
grand canal shops
getting a tour of the one and only
karaoke experience on the strip it's
pretty awesome what you got going on
there rocky
the one and only karaoke spot on the
strip here in las vegas but also
the largest karaoke spot in the country
that's like that's a huge that's a huge
deal
absolutely it's right here in our city
so i want to show you around this is
simba this is our vip host so we're
getting the luxury experience today
so follow us where are we headed simba
this way
okay what room is this wow so this is
actually a good example of the
have you come over here
so which room is this so medium-sized
room called the neon sign room
it's one of our signature room that we
use this uh room as a marketing uh
marketing or
any advertisement yeah i love this
because it's very vegas right
oh and by the way this random guy here
this is evan this is the reason why
karaoke is back in the state of nevada
okay he wrote the protocols so he's the
guy to thank
thank you for joining us evan okay so
let's talk about the luxury experience
what kind of packages can people get
what is
what do people get when they call you
and make a reservation so
the package includes with your 100
bottle two dollars of karaoke and then
two orders of entree
whoo i think you'll be all right and we
see a bunch of fruit platters here but
the menu here
is actually really special this is just
fruit but if you go to the website
you'll see
lobster rolls you'll see it like really
really decadent food
i'm excited to come back for that okay
okay so let's talk about the technology
as well because this is
obviously not your average karaoke bar
this is top notch how does it work what
do we do so we actually do have a
regular character system
and then we also do have a tablet okay
it can uh be connected as a youtube
which
gives you the millions of some varieties
that is so cool and and i understand too
simba that you can bring your own phone
or tablet in and connect your own music
absolutely so if you you know you got
some songs that you've done
in your in your you know if you're
trying out
to get a residency here in vegas this is
where you practice absolutely you can
bring your own tablet or cell phone
with the bluetooth so that your phone
can be a dj machine okay well evan i'm
going to pass you the mic
here you go guys anchors i know you're
in studio waiting for this i want to
hear what your favorite karaoke songs
are but i'm going to press play
so you come down to kamu at the palazzo
practice for your vegas residency safely
because as you can see there's
disposable
barriers on the mic social distance you
ready sit back
sit back sit back what you doing
where are you at ted oh you got plans
just don't say that
with sipping wine sit sit
there you go epic this is just one one
part this is one room out of how many
rooms
we actually do 40 different rooms 40
different rooms and this is a medium
size they have
giant vip rooms anything you want just
head to what's the website
[Music]
it was a bruno mars right their latest
tip that takes you back to the 70s
that's pretty sure